arrivent dans des productions pour
présenter des projets tout ça et tout la
première question qu'on pose c'est
mettez de quelle banlieue en fait comme
si en fait le noir français en fait il
vient obligatoirement de banlieue je
viens pas de banlieue je suis né en
banlieue mais j'ai grandi à caen et dans
un petit village à côté de caen qui
s'appelle if donc je suis un [ __ ]
normand de ouf
j'adore le camembert j'ai regardé
intervilles quand j'étais jeune et je ne
sais pas que j'aime pas les banlieues
tout ça parce que j'allais en vacances à
sarcelles a bondi quand j'étais jeune
mais le fait d'arriver comme ça et on te
dit et quelle banlieue c'est comme si on
te mettait directement dans une calme il
n'y a pas très longtemps là j'étais dans
le xviie
je marchais dans la rue comme ça je
cherchais
l'adresse d'un pote je divague et un peu
je cherchais vraiment le chemin et
finalement je trouve ce chemin et
lorsque j'arrive chez mon pote et tout
c'était un studio en fait d'un mix et il
ya quelqu'un qui tapent à la porte et
qui me dit vous pouvez sortir s'il vous
plaît je regarde le monsieur je dis mais
pourquoi
et le mec il sort sa carte de police et
il me dit sortez s'il vous plaît je sors
contrôles de police pas de patients je
dis mais pourquoi vous me contrôler ils
me disent bas parce que tu avais un
itinéraire bizarre donc voilà le noir
peut pas se promener dans le xviie
tranquillement s'il faut qu'ils sachent
d'où il faut qu'ils sachent où vivent à
quoi et lors de ce contrôle j'avais des
livres sur moi parce que j'adore boris
vian c'était l'époque où je me disais
tous les trucs de boris vian et le coeur
qui me parle comme ça et dans ma poche y
trouve un livre de boris vian
il me regarde il regarde ses collègues
libres ils vivent celui-là
et souvent quand tu discutes avec des
gens ils te disent les arabes on les
aime pas trop mais vous les noirs ça va
vous êtes vraiment j'en tire et ça c'est
un truc un peu énervant mais je me suis
rendu compte que finalement ça venait
des clichés on va dire de l'époque
coloniale tout ça c'est à dire il ya bon
[ __ ] le noir qui sourit le noir qui
est gentil tout ça
au point même que finalement même dans
mon comportement et même sur la fiche du
film en fait j'ai hésité à sourire parce
que j'avais pas envie de véhiculer
l'image du noir il y a bon [ __ ] c'est
à dire que en tant que noir quand tu
arrives il faut que tu sois gentil il
faut que tu rigoles je revendique pas le
droit et de conte à être méchant c'est
normal d'être gentil et bienveillant
envers les gens mais le noir gentil ça
m'agace un peu parce que finalement ça
nous enferme dans un truc un peu
enfantin un peu jovial du noir un peu
gentil tout cela fait ça même ça me
restreins dans mon comportement dans la
vie de tous les jours parfois j'ai envie
de rire avec des gens mais je peux pas
et donc parfois j'ai envie de rigoler
mais je rigole pas fait le roman le
vénère juste pour mettre la bo la
mauvaise ambiance
l'histoire de cette relation entre les
noirs et les blancs elle est méga
complexe il ya une histoire derrière tes
les gens s'en rendent pas compte mais
c'est parce que l'esclavagé la
colonisation tout ça ce sont des choses
qui n'ont pas été bien étudiée en fait
ce sont des choses qui n'ont pas été qui
n'ont pas été réglés dans la société
française et moi je viens quand même une
époque où quand j'étais gosse il y avait
des gâteaux c'était les gâteaux bon bout
là je me rappelle très bien il y avait
les bombes ou là il y avait les têtes de
[ __ ] plein de choses qu'on a vécu que
j'ai vécu - en tant que noir découle de
l'histoire mais le problème c'est que
les gens qui sont en face de moi qui ont
ces comportements là s'en rendent même
pas compte moi mes parents ils viennent
de l'époque où tranquille il n'y a pas
de problème ils baisser la tête
il se prenait des remarques mon père un
toi t'es gentil toi mais mon père voilà
c'est dans l'ancienne génération mais
nous aujourd'hui c'est terminé
et j'espère que le combat qu'on est en
train de mener aujourd'hui pour voilà à
reconnaître un peu l'histoire française
et nous inclure dans cette histoire
française
j'espère que quand mes enfants auront
des enfants que je serai grand père
j'espère que tout ça se sera devenu
ringard et que je serai le vieux cons
qui dira à ses gosses vous savez vous
êtes noir il faut être fier et que mes
petits enfants me le dire en mai
mais papy c'est terminé tout ça j'espère
j'espère en tout cas